[Music]
are you guys old enough to remember that
Demi Moore and Bruce Willis were married
alum anymore what the hardest woman
cerebrate in the 90s in the 90s period
I like Nicole Kidman she was very hard
especially in Batman Forever that's why
I saw yeah we recently watched that
movie and I was like she's hot hi
Michelle Pfeiffer better why did you say
like that
I like Demi Waterson like she has zero
lips you know why Casey cuz we like him
crazy they like him crazy I'm crazy my
friends yes
damn I really had to choose it would be
the cast of Baywatch I was trashy
Oh Pamela Anderson was Jeff [ __ ] Hawn
the show is crazy okay so I do a magic
show one time she did magic
what should I pull a [ __ ] dick out of
her [ __ ] no well she should have Hans
Klok the beauty of magic google it I was
at that show there was they did a bunch
of those shows googly Hans Klok KL
okayed the beauty of magic I went to
this show in Las Vegas Nevada and Pamela
Anderson was magic
hey Manson was the magic [ __ ] Wow we
got her bites odd enough she was getting
sawed in half to here he was the oh yeah
yeah crime though that's like even
naturally she was still so hot cuz I had
no money and I paid like 40 bucks for
the seats and so I was all the way the
back she was hot as [ __ ] what that was
like Borat times right a little after
yeah he's definitely aged and and find
that time I'm not making [ __ ] up I got
that book now or at that time yeah now
she's more guilty she getting sawed in
half they [ __ ] put swords all over
her ass they [ __ ] burned her in a box
they made her disappear she reappeared
the back of the audience said she's
invincible I don't even know how the
clock was there whose magic show I give
a [ __ ]
was it a surprise that she was there you
news on issues and I brought my
girlfriend the time I was like hey baby
take a back seat
I'm here for Pamela not anymore in Bruce
Willis so they were married back in from
1987 to 2000 okay that's when they were
married well that's a lot of time
striptease GI Jane ghost thank you and
[ __ ] the hottest of them all in
my opinion for Demi Moore a few good men
wait which was the one where she's like
Hello stripper e15 oh you disabled which
ones a few good men again
who ordered the [ __ ] Code Red that's
a great movie Ansel couldn't wrote that
movie that's right yeah and then die
hard wasn't that around the same time or
it was that was 88 also it was when they
were married yeah well they I think they
had just gotten together a slash
marriage no they got married 87 is that
right
what about them though okay so about
them it is it has been confirmed that
it's kind of weird I think
and a lot of people think it's kind of
weird that they are quarantined together
the father back and love maybe when when
you know like Bruce Willis has his own
wife like in his old Demi still hot by
the way Demi still hot and it wasn't me
then I was with Ashton Kutcher after I
never married I thought that was weird
oh you like them young huh yeah Bruce
Willis is like a manly dude and you went
to like a boy toy maybe she wanted
something opposite she wanted the pool
cleaner literally the oscillate yeah
hose you wanted a pathway Ashton Kutcher
Minh has so much hair it's crazy whereas
Bruce Willis has [ __ ] not and also
like thing from Ashley Cushman he used
to come into maker studios back in the
day yeah he's a hairy guy and he
invested in maker studios and he haven't
made a killing off of that [ __ ] but ash
to cook Minh was definitely super
hardcore independent she's nearly how do
you have somebody say Howard dipole just
until I go I'm telling you I met him
back then I met Ashton Ashton come on oh
no he cuz he's not all he would talk
about
or am I looking for excuses to say his
name or not not all say those are true
stars yeah he did come a lot of you
married with dad maybe a relationship
l'amour more mm-hmm Demi Lovato Demi
Lovato oh she's still hot by the way
really chooses to the Charlie's Angel
movie like I know five years ago and
she's [ __ ] scorcher here they are
together quarantine so they're with
their boy toys in the back what are
those
yeah that's their daughters those are
kids are there okay so here's a
situation what ended up happening let me
hang out with my ex-wife No so like I
said Bruce is currently married himself
he has a fist 27 they've been married
since 2009 she was born in 1998 she was
born in 1978 not far off ten years yeah
wait wait
Tony you're sorry thank you 188 so she's
in her 40s she is 41 yeah anyway so they
were supposed to meet up together in
Idaho because Bruce and his wife live in
California but they raised their kids
and I though well I think Bruce and Demi
raised her kids Bruce and Demi yes they
did for sure but then Bruce with his his
new kid right there in California and so
got a lot of kids yeah I do have a
complicated situation that sounds
healthy
being like big celebs like I feel like I
would move to somewhere like Idaho too
and raised my family well dude that
[ __ ] Mike Michael Keaton I think Dave
Chappelle did Dave Chappelle to the
kimberlite did that to move to Montana
all the famous who would do that is
because the locals there probably don't
give a [ __ ]
hey Annie know your neighbors and all
night I don't care that lunch was drew
anyway so they were supposed to meet up
and then that's when this whole
coronavirus thing happened
oh wait because of the whole coronavirus
thing happened they were they were
agreeing to go to Idaho like the whole
family even with Demi because I guess
they're cool and so that's when Bruce
ended up going ahead but then the wife
stayed behind because it turns out that
there's
year-old while playing at a park pather
bonus find a hypodermic needle
exactly she found a hypodermic needle
so she poked her shoe with it because
she had never been talked about needles
I guess oh you got to have that needle
talk soon she poked her foot with the
needle so then the wife and the
daughters had to stay behind she got the
no no no so they had to stay behind like
for testing and like to see how things
are and and so that's kind of how that
ended up happening but one of his
daughters who was it I already closed
the thingy but his daughter she was I
don't think it was right the other one
then yeah this one her name is a rumor
got a name is rumor rumor is one of the
Wolves daughters man yeah yeah she is
she is a Willis so she was on a podcast
and and she was talking about the reason
why her parents are quarantined together
so I will her name scout by the way okay
Scout Scott asked out probably at
honestly probably after that movie
addicts Atticus Finch tequila
Mockingbird probably I guaranteed
tequila Mockingbird Scout is the
daughter of Atticus Finch oh that makes
sense that's the most like up there with
the memes go not because she's a boy
scout oh that could be he was in the
movie called the boy scout it's okay
my parents raise notes that's the most
[ __ ] I've ever [ __ ] heard step never
got the talk from my sister like and
then she says that mom later but he's
like apparently never got to talk about
my good pickup a hyper different needle
yeah you think so you think there's like
tension once they get the test results
rained and the baby's healthy whatever
move yeah oh that's good then so they
save themselves some family tension
during quarantine but they really what
riot might be able to true hey mom hey
step mom they don't have to deal with
that yeah that's exactly like that's
kind of awkward isn't it like I don't
know having to be locked up with your ex
after decades sharing the same bed they
have matching onesies so it seems like
they're best friends for a long time
Bruce and Demi that's what I hear in the
mid yet so that's what I believe well
the media isn't gonna say they [ __ ]
hate each other right you know you only
have daughters what about the other boy
what boy
there the other guy there's a lot of
guys Scout Evelyn and Mabel those are
all we saw I just got a Mabel on my on
my on my Island on the animal crossing
shut up about animal cross no key she's
wrong funny guy
play-do we talked about it once at
Subway all right make some some sick-ass
clothes shut up shut up
Mabel's really cool you off to meet her
I find it I'll meet me I'll introduce
you I don't play it you guys do you have
it no I bet I guess we're downloading it
today
I want to play it but I don't have time
but the Wii but okay you play away my
wife was on the phone with TIFF last
night till 2:00 in the morning Tabata
and I'm crossing and so TIFF is [ __ ]
ready
so she was hiding you got lubed up that
whole call well she sold you on that oh
yeah seller - I'm like oh man she just
kept telling me like literally
everything about this game is so TIFF
like you need to [ __ ] killing days on
that thing it's the closest I felt to
the the guy who sends his wife into bars
and has her pole chick so that they can
[ __ ] them that's the closest I felt like
hearing TIFF on the phone Nikki last
night and I might get her in a animal
crossing you can come to our Island
anytime you want sell fruit you plot to
get a better price come to ours I felt
it also maybe okay sorry moving away
from Animal Crossing really quick you
can try this whole try this whole topic
here makes me think like what if people
that are like on the ends of like
breaking up in the relationship and
stuff and then this whole lockdown
happens and then they end up being stuck
together like how [ __ ] awkward is
that or like in a tiny apartment - not
even like a house today there are that
there are a rise in domestic abuse cases
- yeah because it's the animal crossing
fights yeah who's gonna use the Nintendo
tonight who [ __ ] up the Zen garden
rocks I know who did
horrible gun
[Music]